Daily Mail reports suicides hit record
high last year when nearly 50 000
Americans took their own lives cd0
report revealed that suicides in the US
aren't an all-time high I think a large
component of this is
what's what we see in cities obviously
covet I think destroyed a lot of people
the lockdowns and all that stuff but you
come out to the middle of nowhere and
what do you have
fresh running water granted you don't
want to drink wild stuff like you've got
to clean and all that stuff but we have
a well we have a well water with a
filtration system so there's no Gunk
there's no weird chemicals there's no
there's like there's no chlorine I'm
pretty sure we have no chlorine uh we
just it's like a multi-stage filter with
a with a UV light to clean it and kill
the bacteria no fluoride added just
regular oil well water and it's it's we
have the rivers right down the road
fresh fruit growing all across the
property it's ridiculous every month
there's some new kind of fruit to eat
and we didn't even we even put it there
and you can even eat the leaves nobody
wants to but you can a lot of the grape
leaves we got so much grapes oh we can
wrap stuff yeah you could wrap them in
soak them yeah Chuck was talking about
doing that so we're out here and it's
like a Disney fairy tale little animals
running about with deer on the front
door picturesque mountains in the
Forefront with the Clean Air yup you
walk out you look outside you see clean
air you see Mist Rising there's wild
turkeys in the front you could back in
the day
that I mentioned this they have the guns
in the kitchen the the muskets and I
asked the guy like what's the musket for
and they're like oh when they're cooking
dinner they open the back door shoot a
rodent
throw the rodent in the stew and I'm
like wow that's how they live it's like
you need to go honey he's like open the
door and you're waiting you're like
there we go rabbit Bang
so we have wild turkeys in front of the
house all the time
we don't do this but we could literally
just capture killing anyone we have deer
all over the place there's too many deer
actually I hope like the deer need to be
killed I I I'm you know I don't want to
be a dick but there's like 25 of them
and there's poop everywhere and they're
just eating too much so people go out
and they kill them but you could just
eat the deer it's just like the food is
right there in the cities they use all
this crazy chemicals people's heads are
are whacked they're on ssris they live
in Cube they live in these concrete
blocks that smell like sour milk that
break dust coming out of the cars I was
gonna say all the car emissions that
they walk through to get from tiny
apartment building to the time because
it goes into your apartments too it's
like living in a sewer is it like that
in London too you're from outside London
yeah but I don't really spend much time
there but it is I mean the pollution is
really really bad but you know on the
flip side they're trying to push the
climate change thing so they're putting
plant pots in the middle of rides to
stop drivers going into Central London
they're charging people every single day
about 15 just to drive into Central
London so that's even delivery drivers
truck drivers so there's good good and
bad things about that you know I think
it is uh a tough life there when people
are going from the office you know nine
to five they go straight to the house
and they've got a tiny apartment and you
know for a one bedroom apartment in
London it's like 1 200 1 300 so it's uh
you know crammed conditions a bit like
New York so it's not a way for people to
live you know like Tim was saying it's
much better people are happier and
healthier if they're living in the
countryside you know I spend so much
time outdoors and it's so much nicer
it's fulfilling you know you feel that
fresh air and you feel good and you know
you appreciate things like if you grow
your own vegetables you appreciate that
taste you you don't think oh I can just
buy what I want it's you know
consumption it's you actually enjoy life
a bit more yeah here's the crazy thing
the uh they have a racial breakdown and
an age breakdown it is mostly Millennial
white people who are committing suicide
oh my gosh multi-racial people are very
low I love this but what you need to
understand is that white people are the
majority of the population so percentage
is what matters the most
and I think uh who has percentage change
you need to break down the amount of
suicides by race but by percentage of
population so it looks like white people
are committing tremendous amounts of
suicide but it's actually fairly
comparable if you look at black or
African they're about 10 percent of of
you know the white population and that's
actually so it seems statistically
average uh suicide across all uh racial
backgrounds but then you you do notice
that from 25 to 64 substantially more
suicides with the highest demographic
being 25 to 44 which is Millennial into
uh uh younger Gen X
it's freaky stuff man you know what
whatever's causing this people are
having a breakdown I think purpose
matters uh I think we can look at a lot
of the issues that are causing something
like this and they're just directly
correlated with cities no community no
neighbors no purpose living in pollution
and garbage and running back and forth
it must it's like it feels
I don't know man it just feels like the
dark side and they can never get up the
ladder you know they're stuck in those
jobs for their whole life they're just
surviving basically you know paying
their bills and it's really tough and
what's sad as well most these people
likely have mental health struggles and
then you've got Canada that's legalizing
euthanasia including for people with
mental health so how many more people
are going to feel so hopeless that
they're going to take their lives you
know instead of you know sending all
this money to different countries you
know another 24 billion to Ukraine you
know America should be investing in
mental health and let's help these
people we shouldn't be you know pushing
people to you know feel that they've got
no chance in life let's actually help
them and support them with mental health
I think it was someone was just saying
we should reintroduce them reopen mental
facilities was a Vivek was it Vivek do
you guys remember you might have
wouldn't be a bad idea yeah Reagan shut
them down in the early 80s and that was
a big jails instead yeah and now we have
this Mental Health crisis that just
began like right when that big shutdown
happened so maybe it's time to but like
they were so horrible so many people
suffered so horribly in a lot of those
places that that was the justification
for shutting them down but that doesn't
mean that we can't do it right or do
something yeah it also opens the door to
your political dissident so the
government says mentally ill yeah or you
have a medical marijuana card well it's
not federally legal so off to the mental
facility with you and you can't get out
with armed guards yeah with regular
jails you'll get a term
and then you get out maybe you'll get
out with good behavior get out early but
with mental facilities
they determine whether whether you get
out or done I think a lot of these
people are maybe not a lot but returning
veterans from the war in the Middle East
wars in the Middle East when you come
back and you realize like wait there
were no weapons of mass destruction wait
Osama Bin Laden we didn't go into
Afghanistan for Osama Bin Laden I
thought I just spent six to eight years
of my life willing to kill and seeing
people get like uh and people hate me
and look down on me and think that I'm
bad for having been in the middle I mean
like they're veteran suicide is serious
and is part of it I think part of it is
also social media I mean it's something
that we see particularly among young
people anywhere from you know 15 to 35
you're seeing an increase in anxiety
depression suicidal ideation uh so
there might be a lot of circumstances
but I think ultimately we have bred we
have raised young people in a culture of
hopelessness and you must be reminded
that every day if you're working a job
that you don't like in a city where you
feel like no one knows you and you go
home and you lie in bed and look on your
phone for hours and hours and hours and
you feel like you're not getting the
same amount of likes to someone else and
why aren't you doing more with your life
and that despair is is terrible where I
think we need to have a culture that
measures success not by online presence
but in the connections you have in real
life I think if you look at this data
there's a really easy way to uh a really
easy bit of data to show what's causing
this you can see that males are three
times more likely or three or four times
more likely to commit suicide than
females
so I think a large component of this is
telling men they're evil they are bad
they are wrong no matter you know you
know I love there's this article I
talked about the glass Cliff it was like
Linda yakarino's appointed to the board
of X right when the company is about to
implode this is the glass cliff and I'm
like man you got a glass floor you got a
glass ceiling got Glass Walls you got a
glass Cliff ladies be living in a big
glass room is that it don't throw stones
that's right that's what I was gonna say
people who live in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones and so these
people they'd be doing nothing but
throwing stones and so I'm like no
matter what happens to a woman in the
workplace it is the fault of patriarchy
and men and I'm just like dude come on
you can't be like Elon Musk hired who he
thought was the best person for the job
we were very critical of of yakarino I
think it's the name right because she
was a world economic form individual
she's not she's named toss off the glass
cliff she was given a prestigious
position you give a woman an executive
position well it's the glass Cliff to
throw her off the cliff yeah you don't
give it to her it's off to the glass
ceiling you get you you you give her a
mid-tier job and they say well that's
the glass floor women are are thought of
that because they're eye candy oh just
just spare me dude well I mean with
yakarino like them being like they hire
her right as the company was about to go
downhill like are you guys saying she's
not capable of turning it around yes are
you saying that you think she's not
qualified for the job she was given like
are you sort of showing us what's
actually happening here uh I I think
there is such a weird conversation where
women have to be protected at all costs
because they can never think that maybe
a man would have been better for their
position when ultimately we know that
genders are function differently I mean
it goes right down you can study newborn
babies and see a difference in the way
their brains naturally develop you can't
tell me a newborn baby has been
socialized at all uh we know there are
extreme differences and instead of
having a society that prepares people to
pursue things that fall along those
lines we're saying constantly like
something's oppression is pressing you
something's bad actually you're the
problem actually you need to stop the
way you are and conform to what we want
from you it's just toxic I think divorce
is another one I was just watching a
soft white underbelly on YouTube highly
recommend the one with the divorce
attorney that is just recently came out
a few days ago and he was saying that
like in divorce proceedings the guy
tends to get the raw end of the stick
it's like if the guy cheats on the girl
the guy's trash he's a piece of you
know junk if the girl cheats on the guy
the guy probably wasn't doing enough to
support her so she had to go they're
more likely to lose custody of their
children I mean it's to be 18 or 16 I
mean did you did was this around you
this like men are bad is that part of
why you feel like I don't want to be or
I don't feel right as a guy like um so
it wasn't like it is now when you know
the patriarch is constantly mocked and
you saw the Bobby movie that was kind of
mocking men
um so you know you saw the Bob movie
mocking men but um it wasn't around them
but I had a kind of difficult
relationship with my dad he was very
masculine he was trying to get me to do
all these outdoor things and you know I
didn't get on with him so I was trying
to reject that so that was part of the
reason why I became more feminine and
you know more like a girl and stuff but
I think nowadays we're really seeing
this division as you know a breakdown of
masculinity because it's very hard to
find you know just normal masculine guys
now right you know because we're having
a society that's emasculating men and
again the Barbie movie you know I
enjoyed the movie I thought it was cool
I love you know all the colors and the
outfits and stuff but I think it was
mocking men and trying to make men look
bad and tell women you know you don't
need a man you don't need to settle down
and you know they even mock the pregnant
Barbie and that so I think it's kind of
teaching kids you know or teaching young
girls you don't need a man in life and
you know it's essential for starting a
family right and
and growing so um and I think guys are
seeing that and thinking like uh I'm not
needed if they're telling girls they
don't need men and I'm a man that means
I'm not going to be needed why am I even
here I have no purpose yeah and that's
why we don't see a strong solid
relationships anymore or marriages you
know a lot of marriage is failing or you
know people just hooking up on on apps
like Tinder or Bumble because they don't
see the purpose of it you know
everything is so fast in modern society
you just got an app you find someone new
so they don't build that connection
which I think is really sad that was
another thing we were talking about like
50 years ago your pool your dating pool
was like who you knew and who you were
around now even when you're like married
or you're in a fully committed family
relationship if you go to check your
your notifications you see women's faces
like the faces of hundreds of different
women it's just such a like an erotic
mess I it's not it's not natural
stimulation at least it wasn't up to
this now maybe we have to start
considering it I mean it's artificial
but it may be coming part of our nature
but it is counter-intuitive to the
marriage mono uh like monogamy me
structure that's something else that's
the voice divorce attorney was talking
about too
geez what it's a weird a weird but I
mean if we don't have kids then the
human race will not proceed and this is
why
young men are skewing conservative it's
why young men are fans of Andrew Tate
and Jordan Peterson
because you've got finally they're being
talked to they're being explained their
value they're being explained their
responsibilities their opportunities
and the left is really really funny I
think it was vosh who's who tweeted
something like the reason young men are
becoming conservatives because the right
is talking to them we need to do this
and the response from all these leftists
was ah boohoo poor men shut up spare me
blah blah blah and I'm just sitting here
laughing being like just keep on ragging
just keep on hating and more and more
guys are gonna be like screw you I'm
leaving
at first I was hurt by a girl I blamed
her it was my fault a lot of it went in
my 20s so I was like happy to watch this
division proceed in like 2011 12 13 I'm
like good she deserves it all women
deserve it I was so angry and but it's
like a snowball an avalanche rolling
down a hill once it gets started I it's
it's gone out of control now I I don't
know I mean I'm sure we can grains of
sand and kind of slow the thing down
because it's not a literal Avalanche but
it feels like this momentum of
divisiveness between men and women is
has been picking up steam and that's uh
that's concerning of course it's you
know
well I would think movies like Barbie
are sort of accelerating this right
they're saying men are to blame and I
thought Barbie was making fun of women
I've never seen it so yeah I can't
comment I mean I'm sorry I thought it
was more mocking men it was basically
teaching women don't settle down with a
man you don't want to get married and
there was two scenes where there was a
pregnant Barbie and you know Will
Ferrell was the CEO of Mattel and
basically they were mocking the pregnant
Barbie like she was a discarded model so
it was teaching you know young girls you
know don't have babies and there was a
scene at the start you might have seen
it in the trailer where these uh kids
were on the beach and they had these
baby dolls they were looking after them
Barbie came along suddenly they smashed
them so I thought that was almost a
subliminal message telling kids don't
have babies or you know because it's
it's not what we want in society anymore
so I mean I didn't see it but my My View
From the trailers and the commentary
that I have seen is that if the default
presentation of the Barbies is his
happy-go-lucky world and
then she goes into the real world and
it's not nearly as as bad like I I think
it shows them as like Airhead vapid
stupid
lazy entitled like but I didn't see the
movie so I don't know I got a hot take I
don't think Margot Robbie is that good
of an actor am I I've never heard that
she was good you thought she was good
yeah when I look at her face I just
don't see and Margot come on the show I
still love you but like she's just
popular because she's hot and I maybe
maybe I'm wrong maybe she was great in
the movie A lot of stuff no she was in
she's a really good actress yeah Jared
Leto and uh what's that what's that
movie Harley Quinn right Harley Quinn
she was in um that movie was Wolf of
Wall right did the worst one of the
worst movies I've ever seen was Birds of
Prey was she in there and it was just so
I saw a couple scenes with her and Ryan
or not Ryan Reynolds I'm actually upset
you guys made me remember that movie
yeah sorry I mean it's I hate
objectifying other actors because good
for her doing what she's doing but I
think it's a it's kind of an example of
like where our society is at with
auto-tune and like the hot girl gets the
lead because she's hot and not because
the best actors thanks for watching this
clip from the Tim cast I RL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time